this is so good this is my favorite
video i've ever made
and i didn't even make it
hey we're running links and these are
our favorite snacks
let's get some snacks
[Music]
that's right
we're starting off with some chips here
these are my favorite chips ever
ruffles cheddar and sour cream but
they are not alone
when i snack on these puppies i have to
combine them with
holy guacamole
keeping it classy now this is a little
bit of a left turn the guac this
guacamole has zero tomatoes
i approve of zero tomatoes and it's very
garlicky so you gotta watch yourself
look at that i got the perfect chip
now let me just sit right there on top
dink it
and sink it
a lot of flavor happened in my mouth
yeah this is the best guacamole on the
market man this is a bag full of perfect
chips y'all got like a deal
if i'm gonna point out any negative with
the ruffles
cheddar and sour cream it's that you'll
never find a foldy chip which i'm a big
fan of the foldy chips too you can't
have ridges in folds you got to make a
choice in life
i'm gonna eat the whole bag so just sit
tight
oh yes
black licorice specifically australian
style
soft black licorice i can i listen i
know that not everybody likes black
licorice
stink in fact most people don't like
black licorice but most people don't
understand quantum mechanics all right
explain quantum mechanics well i don't
understand it i just like black licorice
you like it no it's it's uh it's nasty
okay let me i have a theory i think
you're tasting exactly the same thing
that i'm tasting everyone tastes the
same thing but everyone interprets a
little bit because i understand why most
people hate this and that's kind of why
i like it because i also like being
spanked make me uncomfortable a little
bit man let's get something from my side
again the good side
oh yeah okay one of my favorite snacks
topo chico mineral water i'm just gonna
speak for the people in the comments how
is this a snack
i like it toppo chico is it a snack has
got the most bite it's so
carbonated that
it's actually a snack
and it's a treat it's a zero calorie
treat man i have one it's a water snack
every single night
listen if you got balls
then this is this is what you want and i
mean metaphorically i want it's for
everybody if you don't have physical
you know what i'm saying
metaphorical you've got hooks i already
knew this but if you've got if you've
got guts if you've got you know what
else i mean i'm going to let you dig
this hole man if you've got i'm just
here to
drink your snack drink my snack man
it's great
big mama
i know you did it yes you did this is
the big mama pickled sausage
i will say if this
reminds you of a dog's penis
come on yeah yeah like listen i don't
fault you for that because it reminds me
of a dog's penis as well
uh which is not appetizing in fact that
speaks volumes to how good this tastes
because i'm able to eat it while
thinking about a dog's penis and still
enjoyed it
dude
i got plenty to go around brother here
we go
take that one i don't even have three if
you want i don't want this
nothing you said well 10 grams of
protein
oh there's nothing better than not on an
erect dog penis
but the flavor and the texture it's
vinegary it's mushy it's uh it's got a
natural hue
very natural looks like something you'd
pick off a tree somewhere
hey this is america's number one pickle
sausage
america is always right
next
oh you got one i got one it's the battle
of the butters
the nut butters i see i've got a peanut
butter jiff specifically and i have got
justin's vanilla almond butter let me
just tell you right now
this is not my snack
oh
this is not my snack this is just a
component of mine this is just a
component of my snack okay okay some
whole house
chocolate chips okay i got another spoon
down here and then i'm gonna do your
thing man take your hand oh gosh that's
too many you like make sure that the
peanut butter will not come in contact
you just kind of grasp it
sort of grasp it like that then you turn
it
and now
do you have a name for this the red
special
[Music]
you need to come up with a better name
for it the nut chip
the reason i do this is just because i
am a human that lives in the 21st
century listen our civilization is on a
decline but there's absolutely nothing
we can do to turn this around at this
point what we might as well be doing
is putting together things that if this
grew on a tree the whole human race
would be gathered around that tree and
we would just eat it until we died
but i can just sit here and make it and
eat it
well let me tell you
pretty good
not bad at all let me show you what i'm
gonna do to mine you definitely want
some milk when you're going in on this
and i'm going all the way back i'm going
in for the nest quick
and i would just open that cabinet get a
heaping spoon full of that
goody goody
dark powder
throw it down in there
remember when we were roommates and cops
hitting that side so much and every
night you would hear me doing this
before i went to bed yeah but let me can
i just show you something can i just can
i just do something like
you can do this without
making it so like especially like that
you're going
proves to me is that you you were
purposely annoying me all those years
that we lived together then you take
your
your spoon and you take your wet milk
spoon and go in there this is just mine
and then what what you do is you put it
down in here
and then you pick it up and you you've
got a little chocolate milk on the spoon
what
all my foods are gross but all the way
you eat your foods are gross that's true
it gives you a little nutty hint
to your that would you call yours nutty
hint nutty hint yeah i like that yeah
mine's a nutty hit makes it sound
scandalous
give me another nutty hit
i just need one just one just one nutty
hit this is so good this is my favorite
video i've ever made
and i didn't even make it it's not even
our channel
what are we saying it isn't why are we
giving the best stuff to another channel
this is not our channel
i thought these people seemed different
wow this was fun if you want to know
what it's like to be at my house at
three in the morning
this is it
[Music]
so those are our favorite snacks we're
red and link and you can hang out with
us every weekday on good mythical
morning also check out sport.com
the tool to tell you the best stuff you
can taste
[Music]